hey you you're a zelda fan right i mean
i'm gonna assume you are since you're
watching this video and all
do you remember how it felt to plug in a
brand new zelda game you've been excited
to play for days and finally seeing the
title screen pop up in front of your
eyes and just staring at it for a while
in complete awe struck wonder i know i
do one of the most
impactful things about seeing a new
zelda games title screen besides trying
to convince yourself you're not dreaming
is the fantastic music that nintendo
always masterfully conducts
specifically for their title screen
intro segments well
most of the time anyway so i thought i'd
bring you my top 10 list of the top 10
title screen themes across the entire
legend of zelda franchise that has
what like 20 games in it now and here to
join me today is a fellow zelda creator
that's new to my channel but has been
making
waves in the zelda community this year
you've heard his name now please give
him a warm welcome
ladies and gentlemen the one and only
croton
hello everyone not to be confused with
the salad topping
although i'm fairly used to that at this
point but i'm so happy to finally be on
the channel
and be sure to check out our other video
that's live right now over on his
channel after you're done watching
this one a link to it will be in the
description below and now without
further ado
let us dive right into the top 10 zelda
title themes since 1986.
for number 10 we're starting this list
off with one that
actually not too many people have played
the title screen to phantom hourglass
even though fans of the windwaker will
recognize the inspiration behind the
scene
immediately as it starts off very
similarly to the theme of the great c
once you get just a few seconds in
you'll realize that it's not so much of
a copy of the original great c theme
but more so a masterful remix that
creates a completely new tune
and even though i wouldn't have thought
it was possible since a great c is such
an iconic theme
the title screen music for phantom
hourglass may just inspire an even
greater sense of adventure
number nine brings us to another recent
release that also wasn't picked up by
just everyone but that still has an
absolute toe tapper of a theme triforce
heroes
and i'll be the first to admit i
actually haven't played this game but
ever since nintendo released the trailer
and ultimately the game itself i have
not been able to stop going back
every now and then and giving this
incredibly catchy title screen tune a
listen
it masterfully mixes in accordions and
flutes and makes me feel like i'm
listening to it on a boat in the middle
of venice italy or something
maybe mario's there i don't know it's a
completely new tune that has no
inspiration from other previous zelda
themes that i can tell
giving this one of a kind title screen a
solid place on my list
[Music]
so
[Music]
up next we have the title screen of the
legend of zelda lynx adventure
or zelda 2 as a lot of people call it
the game released in the wake of the
originals massive success
so it was very important to have another
catchy iconic title screen theme that
could at least be on par with the
original
and oh boy did they hit that goal even
though the audio is clearly dated
the tune itself is as timeless as they
come the theme has an almost suspenseful
opening with the repeated descending
pattern of notes that speeds up until
the real melody hits
and when it does i guarantee you it
would have grabbed your attention
completely
the title music consists of a medley of
songs that perfectly sums up the spirit
of link's adventure
and has you ready to press that start
button no matter how difficult the
challenge will be
[Music]
[Music]
for number seven we have an even more
niche game the spirit tracks
and again i have to apologize and admit
i haven't played this one
either but i promise that's the last one
on this list that i haven't played
now title screens have to give the
player the essence or idea that the game
is centered around
in a pretty short amount of time so of
course music is essential in portraying
this properly when it comes to spirit
tracks though i'm kind of at a loss for
words the title screams adventure of
course but also
travel mystery even sadness for a bit
i'm a huge fan of string instruments in
general
so this one is on my playlist a whole
lot i mean how can you not play the game
after hearing the title screen
i'm honestly asking myself that
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
up next is the title theme to four
swords adventures
it's sitting at number six in this list
because at the time the game released
players were used to the large grandiose
title themes full of adventurous spirit
and in the face of that expectation
players were greeted with a shorter but
very attention-grabbing brass theme
now the majority of the theme is
actually just a remix of the main theme
to the legend of zelda
but the beginning has that riff with the
trumpets that gives the player the sense
of heroic duty too
you know saving the world or something
like that take a listen
[Music]
you know speaking of title themes that
kind of shook up the expectations with
shorter riffs what game did it better
than the iconic
theme from a link to the past no joke i
used to listen to this theme over and
over and over again
even though it's really short just
because it makes you feel like such a
boss this title music embodies what it
means to be
timeless
[Music]
lots of games on this list have title
themes that give very accurate ideas on
what's to come
in their games but few of them actually
use the themes from within the game
itself
but the wind waker broke that trope up
and actually straight up mixes the
game's two stage themes into one
iconic fantastic piece of celtic sound
and glory
by the time you hear the actual themes
within this game and realize that you
heard those themes right off the bat
from foreshadowing the title music
the aha moment is just it it's just
really special okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay y'all what kind of a list would
this be if it didn't include the
og theme that began all themes from the
original legend of zelda
of course you've heard it time and time
again remixed remastered or remade both
in
and out of the other official games but
there's just something about hearing it
as it was for the first time in 1986
a world that didn't have zelda or even
adventure games previously
and to be honest the game wouldn't have
been so successful and wouldn't have
spawned this massive 30 plus year legacy
if players hadn't decided to initially
give it a chance and press
start when they heard this music all
those years ago
so in reality this legendary tune is
responsible for
everything including this video there's
a magic
in these notes can you hear it all right
we're almost there in second place we
have what was previously the most
popular zelda game of all time
prior to the release of breath of the
wild twilight princess's theme is
something else i tell ya
no zelda theme before this one had
featured a choir
but twilight princess came out swinging
and knocked it out of the park
i dare anyone to just try and listen to
this title screen
and think about anything else the sheer
amounts of awe
and epic emotions that begin to swell in
your body while listening to this title
screen
is almost guaranteed to leave goosebumps
up and down your arms and leave you
itching to dive into this game
over and over and when that wolf hollow
hits and menacing plays at the very end
and it seems to just hold itself frozen
in time
afterwards chills
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
at long last we've arrived at first
place
and it is none other than the title
theme to breath of the wild
he's kidding guys it's actually the
title screen of skyward sword
okay okay jokes aside the award for best
title theme of any zelda game ever
has to be given to the soft piano melody
of ocarina of time
now i know some of you will write this
off as a choice made just because of
nostalgia
who knows maybe you're right but let me
put it this way
the legend of zelda's theme was iconic
and original
zelda 2 was adventurous a link to the
past was loud
aggressive heroic and link's awakening
was a remix of the original
when ocarina of time was announced as
the first 3d zelda game with all new
amazing graphics and gameplay and epic
music and
adult link players were expecting a
theme louder and bolder than ever before
to really seal the heroism in their
hearts
and ready them to fight the demon king
himself but when they plugged in that
cartridge
that wasn't what happened no there were
no trumpets
no drums no flashing lights or logo only
a fade in to a hillside silently
in the night and then they ride and a
piano begins to play an emotional tune
that completely blindsided every single
player watching
you hadn't noticed but the game had
already captured your heart
number one goes to the most emotional
title theme of all time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well there you have it my top 10 zelda
title themes of all time did you agree
with the list or was there a theme i
left out
let us know in the comments below and
please be sure to like this video if you
enjoyed and subscribe to help the
channel reach more fans just like you
and me huge thanks to mr croton for
helping out with this video
thanks again for having me dude it's
always a blast being able to just nerd
out about things like this
be sure to check out our other video
featuring yours truly live
right now over on his channel links will
be in the description below and another
massive thanks to all my supporters out
there
introducing the new faces of sam c and
jyn
1412. if you're interested in joining my
elite crew and helping the next video
come to life
you can get started by clicking that
join button below this video or visiting
the links in the description below
also down there are links to my social
media pages so you
better come say hi to me or i'll be sad
very sad okay that's all i've got for
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mass
nintendo bandit signing out
[Music]